okay
this this goddamn little kid
big goddamn knife hey help me
no
[Music]
dick did you do
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
we lost him you can't be far wait hold
on cut your engine
i'm gonna see if there's anything we can
salvage on leon's bike
no goddamn what son of a [ __ ]
guessing that's a fuel line unless you
just piss yourself fuel pump
yeah shout out my damn fuel pump can we
get anything off leon's bike
nah it's done look
let's just go back to o'leary mountain
we'll head out in the morning find some
parts and come back and get your bike
no i think i got a better idea we just
get it while we're out here
what well yeah
crazy willy's isn't far from here let's
just head over there
what are you thinking we were going out
hunting tonight anyway
willy's as good a place as any yeah
okay
hey what did leon give you a map of some
kind
once we get my bike back let's head up
to the cemetery look around
yeah okay
so tomorrow get the drugs take him to
tucker
collect all leon's bounty then i say we
head north
do you think shit's any different up
north don't matter i think you do us
good get the hell away from here
[Applause]
hold on